- Good morning Believe
Nation, today's message
is live and breathe your craft.
Over to you Martin Garrix.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- When I was like eight year old,
I was playing soccer and
like the guys on my team
didn't take it seriously, it
was like oh you want to be a DJ?
I don't know,
I love producing and I love DJing.
So I always kept on doing it, practicing,
trying to get better.
- How many hours a day
are you busy with music?
- All the hours that I'm not asleep.
Literally I wake up
also listening to music.
Music is everything to me.
- [Interviewer] You live and breathe it.
- Here's a guy, Martin
Garrix, 20 years old,
listed to be the number
one DJ in the world.
How can you achieve massive success
in a short amount of time?
You have to live and breathe your craft.
Too many people are not prolific enough.
The people who are the best
in the world at what they do,
they're prolific.
They practice, they repeat over and over
and over and over again in all fields.
How many times have you
seen the best athlete
in whatever sport being the
first person to be at the gym
and the last person to leave.
It's almost a cliche.
But it happens every time.
Michael Jordan had the most success,
Michael Jordan took the
most free throw practices,
took the most jump shot practices.
He practiced, he practiced, he practiced
to hone the natural talent that he had
and make it something extraordinary.
You can't coast alone on talent.
If you do you'll be mediocre at best.
You have to be able to put in the work.
So here's this guy 20 years old,
best DJ in the world because he lives
and he breathes his craft.
You can get there in a short
amount of time if you hustle.
I've told the story about
myself at the agency
that I was at where I was
the worst storyteller,
I was the worst person on camera.
In a couple months became the best
just because I was prolific,
not because I had skill or talent,
but because I worked harder.
I'd be making multiple videos a day
were the people there had a hard time
finding time to make one video a week.
If you're only doing
something one day a week,
it's going to be really, really hard
for you to get better at it.
And the people who really
live and breathe their craft
are going to crush you, they're
going to blow right past you.
And that's sucks if you're that person,
but it's also great if you are the person
who live and breathe
'cause you can pass people
very quickly who have a lot
more experience than you
because you are putting
in the work to get better.
When I was doing my bio video story,
did it 30, 40 times.
I would do it three times a day,
I would send it to my
agent in the morning,
he would give me feedback,
I'd do it again at lunch,
he'd give me feedback,
I'd do it again in the evening,
he would give me feedback
and I would make it better and
better and better and better.
And those were long videos.
Those were like 20 minute videos.
It wasn't just two minutes.
I redid the whole thing each time
and I sent it to him and he watched it
and he gave me feedback and
I did it again and again.
I'm going through this
process with Lilly now
where we're starting this
project of unlocking Lilly
to help turn her into a public speaker.
We're doing the same thing.
Her first video she shot almost 100 times.
Then she sent me a version
and I said do it again.
Sent me another version, do it again.
Other versions she didn't send me
because she knew it wasn't very good
and she wanted to redo it
and tweek and tweek and tweek
and tweek it and still
this is nothing compared
to where she's going to be able to be.
But she hasn't quit her job
yet, she's working full time
and she's still finding time.
She said before I go to work tomorrow,
I'm going to go outside
and I'm going to film it.
When I get home tonight,
before it gets dark,
I'm going to film another version.
She's grinding, she's hustling,
so she's going to get better faster.
You have to live and breathe your craft.
If you want to be the best
in the world at what you do,
you have to practice.
It's not going to come
from just doing something
one day a week.
So the question today is
what is your craft,
what are you beating on
every single day to try to get better
so you can be one of the best
in the world at what you do,
what is it?
Leave it in the comments
below, I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Rick Verwimp.
Rick thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, I really
appreciate the support.
I hope you're enjoying the book
and you're applying some
of the lessons to your life
and to your business.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you and hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- So what advice would you give purely
in an acting sense to yourself
30, 40 years ago?
- Same advice I gave
myself 30, 40 years ago.
Get a job.
(laughter)
Act.
There are
unfortunately those of us
who say well I want to be
a star.
That's
way out there in the ether somewhere.
I want to be a working
actor, you can pull that off.
So act, work.
Work,
someone asked me once and
you're about to do it,
(laughter)
What would you do if you weren't an actor?
If you didn't make it as an actor,
what would you do?
I have no idea.
I would act somewhere.
Maybe I'd be driving a cab,
maybe I'm working somebody's yard,
whatever I'm doing, I'm
going to belong to somebody's
little theater group, I will act.
'Cause I'll die if I don't.
- Watch as many movies of
as many eras as you can.
When I was coming up through the ranks
there was a thing called
a cinema club in the 70s
where you thread a 60 millimeter film
and you projected it and
I became familiar with
people that are important to me like _,
like Lauren Hardy, the Three Stooges.
You became familiar with _,
you became familiar with
everything from comedy
to drama.
You can see Preston Sturgis,
don't just limit yourself to
what is out there or the latest
top ten in the box office.
That's the main tool.
And by live film history.
Because you're part of that now.
Even if it's not film anymore,
you're part of that narrative tradition.
The second thing I feel very important,
do not get wrapped in the
industry side of this.
That's what I find really heartbreaking
that people are now a lot
of times you're discussing
film with people that love film
and it's like you're listening to an agent
from an agency or a head of a studio.
They know the grosses,
they know who's doing this.
That's absolutely not important.
The important thing is that
tradition you're going to
belong to and do not get
caught on the other side.
Stay true to the other side that needs you
and needs to _ urgently.
- By the time I got to college
I made this album called
the Language of My World.
(cheers)
And with this album
I did the same thing, I
locked myself in my room
for like almost college, that was it.
I just worked my ass off in my room
and kept writing, kept
recording and I wasn't great
going into college but
by the time I got out,
I had kind of learned a
little bit of the craft.
And by the time that I got out of college
I read this book called
Outliers by Malcolm Gladwell.
Nobody here's read it.
One person, anyway this book examines,
this book examines this ferry right
and Malcolm Gladwell makes this point,
he says it's not about what _,
it's not about the talent
that you're born with,
it's about the hours that
you put into that talent.
And he says that around,
if you want to be a master
of whatever it is that you love to do,
if you wanted to develop that
craft to its upmost potential,
what you've got to do is work.
You have to work a lot,
you have to put in hours.
And he says that if you
put in around 10,000 hours,
just about one thing
that eventually you will
master that craft.
I don't know how close
I am to 10,000 hours
but every single time we step on stage,
we get one step closer.